Welcome back, Master and Ma'am!
Hello, hello, hello, hello, hello!
Hello, everybody!
I was just saying...
In loading screen chat...
Welcome!
Please take a look!
I was just saying in loading chat...
Not quite pre-chat.
My computer has another strange sound.
I don't know what it is.
Just sometimes I hear like a...
It's not like my computer computer.
It's like...
On here.
Sometimes I just hear like a...
Thunk!
Hold on.
It happened when I was typing.
No!
It's a blast, but those last few levels are sadistic.
I heard...
Okay, so...
That...
This game has like a real difficulty spike.
Hold on, I'm trying to see if I can activate the noise.
I'll tell you if it happens.
I can't guarantee if we'll beat the game today.
I do have a meeting tonight.
So...
Found your channel today thanks to a clip from a duo with...
Wow, thank you!
Thanks for coming to check me out!
Right now I'm...
I don't know.
You know what?
Nevermind, I give up.
If I hear it though, I'll be like...
That was it.
That was it!
I'm afraid you have multiple hauntings.
No, I don't know.
Is it coming from the case or the speakers?
From the speakers!
I don't know.
So mysterious.
Haunting.
I just heard it.
No you didn't!
This game sounds unrealistic.
Who would want to kiss a ghost?
P.S.
You smell.
Yeah, right!
Who would...
Who would want to kiss a ghost?
I'd be so...
Thanks for haunting us, Bito.
Thank you for letting me haunt you.
Yeah, I don't really know anything about this game besides what the trailer showed.
I don't know...
Like I said, I don't know if I'll be able to beat it today.
Or anything like that, but we'll see.
We will see.
Are you afraid of kissing ghosts?
No!
I want to kiss the ghosts.
I want to kiss the ghosts!
That's the goal.
Is to kiss the ghosts.
Saw Mint's stream on the Steam's Awaria Discord.
Wait, what?
No way.
All the invisible ghosts floating around you probably kissed thousands.
I mean...
I can see them.
So like...
Maybe you have.
But you can also see ghosts if you can see me.
Unless...
Do you think there's like...
Other ghosts?
Like beyond ghosts?
Do you think ghosts have ghosts?
I hope she doesn't carry salt.
Well, wait.
No salt.
I only got the chance to say I really enjoyed your performances on AWA last week and keep it up.
You're amazing.
Thanks, Paige!
I saw your picture with Emojie.
What do you know?
I'm a ghost.
What a marvelous coincidence.
Are you here to kiss ghosts?
The ghost ghost is a toast.
Known by the most.
Are we here to kiss ghosts?
Let's try.
To kiss a ghost.
Banger soundtrack, right?
Oh yeah, I forgot to mention this game is by the Helltaker dev.
So...
A little sadistic.
Probably.
We'll see.
I don't know.
Who knows?
I might game.
Right?
Wait.
Udoki and the girls did amazing at the concert.
Thank you, Croesus!
I'm sorry.
Lord Croesus.
Is the logo supposed to be off-center?
Yes.
Like, this is normal.
Yeah.
Minto Gaming.
I'm gaming.
Also, AKS, I read your letter.
Thank you.
I read your letter.
I forgot to say about a letter I got.
I don't know.
Rezzy Ian.
I think I'm saying it right.
If you're here, you asked in your letter if you can do an Itasha.
Of course you can!
If anybody ever wants to do anything like that, of course you can.
Of course you can.
I would be honored, honestly.
Who are you gonna call?
Ghostsmooters!
Oh, Lad!
Laddora!
Playing freaky game on my birthday.
Do you mind if I ask for the Minkius Metal Gear Solid birthday song, please?
Didn't you also send me a letter?
Sure!
Didn't you also send me one?
Sorry, I'm really bad about writing down.
I only get so excited about reading them.
I like open them all up and then like...
I like get excited about reading them and I'm like, wait a minute.
But yes, of course I can sing!
Happy birthday, congratulations!
Happy birthday with salutations!
Happy birthday, may your sky stay blue!
Happy birthday to you, Laddora!
Happy birthday!
I love when Huey sings this song.
Shut up, Huey!
Cool.
Are we ready to try it?
Maybe.
Are we ready?
Saw you live in Atlanta over the weekend, you and Doki and everyone were fantastic!
It was my first concert ever too!
Wow, thanks for letting us be your first concert!
Thank you!
Ready?
Are we ready, guys?
I'm nervous.
I'm playing on mouse and keyboard.
Hopefully that's okay.
She's a phantom.
Mint phantom, phantom phantom.
Same winter sales happening, so I can gift Ace Combat 7 to otherwise.
I don't know if Matara ever accepted my gift.
I'm not sure, actually.
I gifted her Ace Combat.
And then I got an email that was like, your gift has not been accepted yet.
And if it's not accepted, we're gonna give you a refund.
Chapter 1.
Zambora.
Word from your boss.
You must be the new girl.
That's me.
You want sector F?
It's yours.
Fix the generators and don't let those bitches kill you!
So standard... Oh no, no, no.
Let's try a standard mode.
Your drone will save you from death on a 10 second cooldown.
Time limit is... There's a time limit.
And drone cooldown is greatly reduced.
Drone is gone and generators die faster.
Good luck.
Oh my gosh.
Now let's just try standard mode, right?
Is that the bitch we're supposed to be looking out for?
Because I'm sweating.
Shut up, Liam!
Van Ripper is pretty cool making a game where you kiss demon girls in business suits.
To kissing ghost girls in skin tight suits.
So he can sell us his recipes for sweets.
Good luck on hard mode.
Oh, so
I go and what do I do?
Oh, enter.
Enter?
Enter.
Wait.
What am I doing?
Is there a tutorial that I should have done?
I think this is the tutorial.
I got the mechanics fixed.
This is the tutorial.
There's only one generator, so...
I'm just gonna keep having that go.
Watch out.
How are you supposed to...
How are you supposed to know?
Oh my gosh.
OK, I get it.
Why is the generator so fragile?
I guess I... Oh, I go check.
OK, I understand.
I go check.
Fixed!
Wow, that was so easy.
Smooch at the ghost.
Oh, my head.
You did something.
You fixed the shields, didn't you?
My powers are fading.
You guys would...
So soon?
So soon!
Get smooched, ghost!
Get smooched!
You're trying to mock me, aren't you?
Next time the shields fail, you'll pay for this.
Paranormal warning.
Word from your boss.
Ghosts feed on human emotions.
They want your pain, anger and fear.
Without the shield generators, they'd rip us to shreds.
I'm highly in support of ghost kissing.
We're kissing!
We're gonna get mono!
Zamora 2.
OK.
Tunnel runner, your shift begins.
Oh, golly.
OK.
This guy.
Fixed.
Good to know.
Oh, my gosh.
Oh, gosh.
No, no!
I just barely managed to avoid... Wait, I already saw what I needed.
Oh, my gosh.
I'm gonna... I'm gonna... What do you need?
I think I... Please, let me... Let me... Crap!
Kiss, kiss, kiss.
Get smooched, get smooched, get smooched.
Hard mode unlocks more images in the gallery.
Really?
Aren't you tired of all this running?
You know I will catch you eventually.
What is this?
Are those pies filled with pudding?
I'm trying to be menacing and cool and you're ruining it.
You know that, right?
Ghost is weak to pudding pie.
Out of the 9 new girls we got yesterday, you're the only one still alive.
Keep up the good work.
Cut wire.
Oh, no.
She's already looking like my type.
A little crazy.
OK.
Is there like any... What is this?
This?
What did I... What is... Oh, I take it.
I understand, I understand.
We learn.
We listen and we don't judge.
She's so cute!
I like... Wait, they have the Awaria hats.
Do you think they're like ghosts of the people that...
People that died, I think.
Oh my goodness.
Wait, did I not put it in?
There we go.
Oh my gosh.
Wait, I need to go there!
You!
No!
Please...
It's gonna... It's gonna... I'm gonna... It's gonna... Please!
Wait!
Wait, what did I get wrong?
I'm confused.
Didn't I grab it?
Wrong item?
There's more than one?
How is there more than one item?
It wanted the... It's an uncharged one.
So there's a difference.
Oh my gosh.
OK, so this is uncharged?
I see, I see, I see.
I see, I see, I see, I see.
Understandable.
Understand, understand.
Oh my god.
Only level 2.
It's only level 2.
Oh no.
Give me.
That's OK though.
We're doing our best.
Oh my gosh.
What do you need?
Regular.
This thing.
This damn thing.
OK, there you go.
Oh my god.
Wait, this one is broken too?
Charged.
Oh, they're both charged.
Oh my god, please.
Please.
Oh, I should have fixed the other one first.
I'm an idiot.
Oh no.
Oh
my god.
They die so fast.
OK, put you in there.
Goodness gracious.
Give me a break.
What do you need?
I gotta... I gotta focus.
Just regular.
Charged.
Ouch!
You... Oh my god.
What?
I only got caught twice.
Are you kidding me?
What do you need?
This is not easy mode.
This is normal mode.
I don't play on easy mode.
What are you talking about?
I have to, like, bait her into... you know.
Oh my gosh.
Oh god!
Try to move!
Oh my god.
Oh my god!
This game already scares me.
This is only level 2.
This is insanity.
And here she comes.
Oh my god.
I wonder if this would be easier on controller.
Not gonna lie.
I think this might be easier on controller.
Because...
My fingers don't move.
Unless... Can you play WASDA?
Oh, you can!
Okay, nevermind.
Because I'm... Okay, I was playing with, like, the arrow keys.
And going from the arrow keys to enter was, like, so difficult for me.
Why?
It's because I was playing...
I was playing something else earlier that doesn't let you play with WASDA.
It only lets you play with the arrow keys.
And so I was used to it from earlier.
Okay, okay.
So I was already, like, in the mode.
The arrow key mode.
Okay.
Alright.
Oh, I always forget to put this in.
You know?
Okay.
It's always normal, the second one.
Alright, now we're gaming.
I say.
I lied.
Oh my god, I'm gonna die.
Oh
my god.
Okay.
Oh, I did it again.
I do it every time.
I'll learn my lesson someday.
Oh gosh.
I tried to bait it, but I went too far.
Oh shi...
Oh my god.
I think this is harder than Touhou.
I'm not gonna lie.
Can I grab more than one?
Oh, I can.
Okay, that's kinda nice to know.
Come on.
Sure.
Oh no, no, no, no.
Please be...
Please.
This is so not forgiving with the...
With your life.
Please.
Oh my god.
Yippee!
Oh my gosh.
Cut wire one.
Finished so soon and here I was having so much fun.
I'm ready to kiss!
Ah, you liked it too, didn't you?
My kiss has been secured.
Yippee!
We're kissing, we're kissing.
Whoa.
Oh wait, this is the thumbnail.
Don't worry, I'll always be there.
In the shadows, waiting for the perfect moment to stab you in the back.
Awaria means malfunction in Polish.
Interesting.
Cut wire two.
You'll never believe it, little pup.
They just refilled our...
Denaturat.
Supply.
This is going to be a fun week.
Denaturat.
Is it a rat poison?
It's pure alcohol.
Ghost repeller?
It's...
Denatur...
Alcohol.
For them ghosts with them dentures.
You know what I also like?
Is that each chapter you can play, you can change the mode.
It's kind of nice.
Your drone will save you from death on a ten second cooldown.
Here we go.
Okay, so soon.
Alright.
What do you need?
Regular, got you.
Cut wire two.
She's so cute.
Okay.
Oh, okay.
You're just following me?
Okay.
This is so evil!
Oh god!
Oh shit.
First try?
I think I'm gaming.
First try, baby.
I'm ready to kiss.
Double kiss.
Second one we didn't get a kiss.
The second kiss.
Oh my gosh!
I can't believe we can kiss so many ghosts today!
Yeah!
Look how cute they are!
See, I told you she would give you a kiss if you tried to murder her.
Look, we even got a box of pudding pies.
We're kissing?
Peek.
I actually have a Helltaker...
I have the...
What's it called?
The pop-up parade.
The pop-up parade figure.
From Helltaker.
I like that game.
It was fun.
Cerberus?
No, I'm pretty sure it's Lucifer.
Hold on, let me double check.
It's been a long time since I've seen their names.
Sorry if you heard TikTok.
TikTok.
Lucifer pop-up parade.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Lucifer.
Kiss himself!
Thanks for the time gifted!
Thank you!
Thank you, thank you.
Alexis, happy birthday!
Happy birthday to you!
Happy birthday, dear Alexis!
Happy birthday!
Nikita.
Most of the ghosts used to be tunnel runners, just like you.
I called it!
Remember I said earlier, I was like, I wonder if they're former...
Because they're wearing the hats, I was like, I wonder if they're former workers.
Unfortunately, death took away their memories.
We're late!
Thanks for the time gifted!
Have you pre-ordered the Figma Solid Snake?
I have!
I have, I have, I have.
Why does she look like the Fury?
I'm scared.
The animation is so cute.
Oh gosh, it's this again.
Oh, now we have to combine everything?
Oh god, okay.
Holy moly.
Low tier smelter.
She's coming for me!
Oh, no, no, no, no!
Wait, watch it!
Leave me alone!
I can't check it right now though!
This is what I need.
Ouchie, ouchie.
Oh, shit, shit, shit.
Nice dodge, nice dodge.
I
tried to get it!
There we go.
Another
year passes from my birth into a blizzard at the beach.
I feel I've reached the age where it's all a little bit downhill from here.
Downhill is good!
But that's just how it is, so I just want to say thank you for being the special kind of weird and goofy that brings joy to it all.
Downhill is where it's gonna go fast!
And fun!
That's why downhill is the best part of the rollercoaster.
Happy birthday to you!
Happy birthday dear the villain!
Happy birthday!
And Elsa!
Thank you for the ping!
Ghost girl keeps squealing.
We love it.
I'm squealing like a pig.
That's some pig.
Looks like mommy's out of juice.
How embarrassing.
Are you guys ready to kiss?
Ready!
To kiss!
Smooching time!
It's better than what I could have imagined.
You're a tiny one, aren't you?
I swear I could eat you in a single bite.
What are you doing?
I'm supposed to doodle here!
To give you my combined birthday and Christmas wish.
To keep the spirit.
I have a spirit!
Being the best you, always.
Thank you for coming back and promise to never die.
Oh, it's a Team America joke.
To fill up character count.
Merry early Christmas.
Merry Christmas!
I feel bad though.
Your birthday is so close to Christmas.
Did you have to have a combined Christmas birthday?
When you were a kid?
Did you have all your presents in the same time?
I always felt bad for people like that.
Because usually you expect to get more presents because they are all at the same time.
But they just never consider that.
Spank!
Thanks for the 20k!
I'm dead!
Thank you so much!
My birthday is the 24th?
No way.
I got to sing you a happy birthday on my favorite.
It sounds even more special that way.
I don't know.
It was okay for me?
That's good.
My birthday is exactly halfway through the year.
Optimal birthday Christmas separation.
But what if Christmas in July?
What if?
You know?
Having a birthday on the 18th got them put together?
Even the 18th?
I feel... Honestly, I feel anybody with a birthday in December kind of gets... kind of gets...
Shafted, you know?
So I'm really sorry.
But I prefer my food properly baked.
Come visit me in the kitchen when the shield's down, okay?
Why do they just expect the shield's gonna be down?
Nikita too.
Our boss is eating the pudding pies.
Thanks for the pudding pies, pup.
Where did you get these?
Is your mom working in the VIP warehouse or something?
Why are there so many ghosts in here?
I have so many questions.
Dang, no kiss.
But here we'll get the kiss for sure.
The kiss of death.
Look!
We have the step stool!
We're getting the kiss.
Kiss motivation activated.
Oh, wow, that was really fast.
That was... Oh, okay.
Got it.
Oh, the gear.
Oh my gosh, metal gear.
Oh my god, both are metal gear.
Ah, shit.
Oh my god, wait, it has to activate?
Oh my god.
Wait, I'm not doing so well, you guys.
I'm not doing...
Okay, redo.
Oh, this one already died.
Okay.
Okay, we fix.
This one is this guy.
Oh gosh.
What do you need?
Metal gear.
Branzini!
Thank you so much for the tiny gift.
Thank you.
Okay, grab this first.
Grab this.
Grab...do that.
Okay, metal gear.
Metal gear?
Metal gear.
I grabbed the metal gear.
What happened to the metal gear?
Why did it disappear?
Metal gear.
This is a metal gear again.
And metal gear.
Maybe I did that.
Oh, I forget to always activate it, reactivate it.
Okay.
Oh my goodness.
Okay, metal gear.
Metal gear is loading.
Metal gear.
Metal gear fix.
Metal gear loading.
This is down.
What do you need?
Metal gear.
Why does everything need metal gear?
What do you mean?
Oh my god.
Fixed.
I ran right into it.
What do you need?
Metal gear.
Grab metal gear.
Oh my god.
Come on.
That was so cheap.
What do you need?
This thing.
Do you need a metal gear?
No, you need this thing.
Oh my gosh.
The game is switching it up on me all of a sudden.
Oh, metal gear.
Oh, the other one is closer.
Wait, please.
I have it.
Wait, do you need metal gear now?
Oh, it needs a metal...
I'm not noticing when I'm fixing it.
Oh my god.
Metal gear.
Rude.
So rude.
Does it need two things sometimes or am I crazy?
Metal gear.
Wait, what is this?
Am I not holding one?
Am I crazy?
I'm crazy.
Crazy.
These machines are terrible.
Oh my god.
What's blowing up?
Oh, that is...
The thing that needs to be fixed.
I'm an idiot.
Oh god.
You guys, I'm regressing.
I did so well with the other ones and now I'm regressing.
What the...
That's what I mean though.
Does it...
Just a regular.
Fixed.
Metal gear.
What do you need?
That.
OK, I got you.
What do you need?
A regular.
Got you.
Oh.
Shit, shit, shit, shit, shit, shit.
They do need two sometimes.
Sorry, if you guys are... You're probably yelling in the chat like...
VTuber!
Of course it needs two!
Just look at the picture!
But I'm too busy gaming.
I'm too busy thinking about kisses.
I wasn't mentally prepared for a Metal Gear stream today.
Hey, what's the ladder for?
Ready to kiss.
It's so funny, there's actually an idol group called Ready to Kiss.
I don't really like their music so much though.
I have to like an idol group's music to like them.
Even though they have some of the cutest girls.
So if you look up Ready to Kiss, you'll find the idol group.
They're really cute.
But their music is so...
It's so generic.
It's so... I was like...
There's a couple of songs that I really like.
Like Tai Ni Ikitai.
I was gonna ask some recommended songs.
That one's cute.
Tai... Ni Ikitai.
And it's a cute pun.
OK, are you guys ready to kiss?
Let's kiss!
Oh stop it, you tease.
You know I can't do fire when the shields are up.
We got our kiss!
Kiss secured.
I'm sure you'd catch it nicely though.
Let's find a working furnace and mommy will...
Will cook you properly.
Everybody's gonna be putting in their job applications to Awaria.
Or is it Awaria?
What's the pronunciation?
If it's Polish.
Or is it something completely different from what I'm saying?
Awaria.
Awaria or Awaria?
OK.
Nice.
Word from your boss.
Zamora3!
Oh, she's back.
I'm sorry you've been thrown into this pit with us.
But I've been running the tunnels for 20 years by now.
And I can tell you've got talent for this job.
Me?
Oh
no, not with Wirecutter.
No.
And there's Electric Shocker.
What do you need?
That?
Wait, I just gave you that.
Did I not?
Did I not grab that?
Do I lose things?
Low tier Shocker.
Again.
You drop things.
You can only hold two things.
I
have pockets!
I must have pockets!
Oh my god, I'm just trying to get over here lady.
What does it mean?
Oh, I was already holding one.
Oh my god.
No!
That's so unfair.
Are you kidding me right now?
Are you kidding me?
We gamed.
Oh,
I just noticed the other one is down too.
Oh my god, two things.
Ouch!
Oh,
it's so tricky.
Holy moly.
So tricky.
Especially having these.
There she is.
And they're in the corners, which doesn't make it much easier.
No!
Please!
Gear.
Metal gear.
Oh my god.
Again!
You son of a bitch.
Oh my god.
Why?
Okay.
I'm wondering if I should just hold on to some stuff, but I don't want to drop things.
See?
Now I have to drop that.
I'm gonna drop something.
You have to get so up close to it, you know?
Again!
Okay.
The time limits I've noticed are longer though.
Oh shit.
We lead them to one side, then we...
Fix.
Oh my god, so...
Oh, this is so rough.
This one's tricky, tricky.
Oh nice.
That was lucky.
That was so lucky.
I was the only way I could get out.
Gear.
Metal gear.
That was close.
Gear, metal gear.
I love when metal gear...
Oh, I don't love when I don't do it again though.
Okay.
Oh my god.
I have to bait it?
No, no!
Why?
I love cheese as much as the next person, but...
I don't know if I would love it enough to steal it.
Come on.
How many do I have to fix?
Seven?
I have to fix seven of them?
Holy cow.
Oh god, I got stuck on the wall!
I got stuck on the wall.
I wish it wasn't like so...
Oh, I knew I was gonna get got by that.
I had to though.
I had to go in there.
But I could've like baited it and then left, right.
I get stuck in the... I hate that there is such in corners.
Otherwise, like you can't...
Just kind of like graze the wall for it.
Which kind of sucks.
Oh, hello.
I didn't notice she came in.
Hello?
Fix.
Get fixed.
Ok.
And break.
You...
Ouch, ouch, ouch, ouch.
Ouch.
I'm surprised that didn't get me.
I'm not gonna lie.
Oh, it's already down again.
Stop following me!
Come on, man.
How am I supposed to fix it otherwise?
If I'm not standing up against it.
And then you stand there.
Like the...
Like the unfair player.
That you are!
Wait, why did I grab that?
I don't know.
Hopefully it's for this.
No, but the Metal Gear!
I
don't know how I'm gonna... You guys, I don't know.
I don't know.
Metal Gear or... Wait, I have that thing.
I'm holding on to it right now, literally.
Stop posting these things!
There's so many of them!
These!
Stop!
Come on!
At least it's one of these.
One of these.
Oh my gosh.
Juked!
I don't know how I juked it, but I did!
Oh my god, there's no way.
Unless I'm super lucky.
Oh, and I didn't press it again.
Nice!
This is only easy mode.
Oh, not easy.
Sorry, this is normal mode.
How is... I can't imagine how hard hard mode is.
Do you think they'll kiss me?
Like one on each cheek?
It's all your fault, you wordless piece of shit!
You are only the second most annoying idiot I know.
I'm ready to kiss them both.
I'm ready to grow two mouths.
I
called it!
Me too, me too.
Sorry.
Yeah.
Okay, sorry.
Anyway.
Sorry.
I'm gonna go to the bathroom real quick.
I'm going to the little ghosties room.
In a moment.
One moment.
I just gotta pee.
Sorry.
I'm back, I'm back.
Hold on one second.
I have to check something on my phone real quick.
I'm checking, I'm checking.
She's back.
I'm back, baby.
What the... What the heck?
How are you?
What are you saying?
Why are you guys... Why are you...
Can't wait for all the freaky artwork.
What are you saying?
Thanks Mint.
Oh my god, please.
I've changed my mind.
You are both equally infuriating.
High five!
Nice.
Word from your boss.
Zamora 4!
Stay away from the lower levels, pup.
Shields barely do anything down there.
Leave that stuff to the veterans.
Is that the hard mode?
9 is where it actually gets tough.
I think it's already tough.
Right?
How many levels are there?
I'm curious.
13.
Oh, nice.
I thought it would be less than that.
OK, good.
The lower levels are other sectors, maybe.
Maybe.
Stop kissing!
What is going on?
No, it's all sector F.
Oh, what I meant was like...
Hold on one second.
Oh my gosh.
No!
Oh no!
I was on a... I forgot.
I was on a... I was on like a customer support chat thing.
And I completely forgot about it.
And then I just saw it being like...
New message!
And it was like, you've been idle for too long.
I hate that!
Oh, oopsie.
Yeah, I'm streaming.
Is that the sound?
That must have been the sound!
I was just like, what is the sound?
And it was the customer support chat!
What?
You ghosted them.
Gosh.
Where is customer support Johnson when you need him?
The guy is just customer Johnson now.
He gave up his life of support.
Mystery solved!
Good, because I was so confused what that mysterious beeping was.
Now I know.
Okay.
Oh, what I meant though by the sectors is I think someone was saying like, maybe like sector E, sector D, sector C, things like that.
Maybe those are like the lower levels is what they were, like someone mentioned that, what they were referring to.
Someone in chat was also saying it too.
Detective Minto does it again.
Ghost the customer support while playing a ghost kissing game.
Make sure to leave a good survey review for their trouble.
I know, right?
They even helped me with my issue.
And I just didn't have a chance to respond because I was streaming.
Sorry, customer support.
Okey dokey.
Let's do it.
Oh, what is this now?
Oh, it needs this to then... Oh, interesting.
Okay.
Alright.
And this is broken and needs this generator thingy.
And you're back.
Hello.
Oh, I totally walked right into that.
Silly me, Metal Gear.
So are we gonna get... Oh, this is also Metal Gear.
And I didn't update it.
Oh my god.
Oh, please.
Please.
Oh my gosh.
Why?
What?
There's two of them?
This is messed up.
This is so messed up.
Please, can I... Can I... I'm coming through.
I think something needed Metal Gear.
Oh, this needed Metal Gear.
And then... Oh no, no, no, no.
This one's about to explode.
Uh-oh.
It only showed one picture.
I thought it was good with one thing.
Oh, we're so boned.
That's it, everybody.
Sayonara.
Sayonara!
We almost had it.
We were so close.
But I got the idea of it now.
So, not so bad, I suppose.
I suppose.
It's good to maybe carry this around.
Oh, wait.
Oh, ouch.
I did not notice that.
I'm so dumb.
I tried moving.
I'm stupid.
OK, there we go.
We'll wait for my drone to come back, you know.
There we go.
Okey-dokey.
Nice.
OK.
Oh, wait.
Where's my drone?
Oh, there's my drone.
My little drone man.
OK.
That's easy enough.
Come on.
Drone MVP.
I'm guessing...
It's this again.
It's just a sneaking suspicion.
Yes.
Hello, ma'am.
Metal gear.
Goodbye.
We did so good in the first round.
We did so good.
No!
I need to get through.
Oh, it's this one now.
Interesting.
Is it gonna be this?
Yep.
Oh yeah.
You never realize how long 10 seconds is until games like this.
You know what I mean?
You never realize how long 10 seconds can be until a game like this.
Oh my gosh, please.
Let me through.
Oh, I needed a gear too?
Oh my gosh.
Shit.
That was greedy.
That was greedy there.
They were juking.
I was trying.
Hello.
Oh god.
Okay.
And a gear.
Metal gear.
Hello.
I wish it would show two pictures.
If I had two things to be repaired.
Shit.
It does?
But there was one time when I was going to it and it only showed one.
And then two popped up.
No?
I swear.
Why would I make that up?
I'm so... I got stuck on the wall.
I got stuck on the wall.
One guy.
That was my own eyes.
Already?
Wow.
Okay.
Greedy.
Shoot you.
Oh my gosh.
I hate.
I hate these damn little things.
How is it getting more difficult than this?
How?
Oh my god.
Girl has two left eyes.
Clearly.
What?
Hello?
Fix it.
There we go.
Oh, I had to unlock what the problem was first.
Oh, again?
You.
Out of my way.
Leave me alone.
Oh shit.
There we go.
Okay.
Not being greedy.
I'm not being greedy.
Get it on the way over there.
And what's this?
Oh my god.
That was so close.
Oh shit.
I forgot to do the metal gear.
Activate.
Thank you.
Oh please.
Come on.
You can't be serious.
She is supposed to be the deadliest ghost in the sector.
What a joke.
Smug.
That's me.
The deadliest ghost in the sector.
Obviously.
Duh.
Sorry.
Every time I click out of the game, the music stops.
It's one of those types of games.
Am I blocking too much, by the way?
I just realized.
Am I blocking a lot of the game?
You can just tell me to move.
Just be like, hey Minto, I can't see the screen.
It's not really a good place for me to go to.
A bit, but that can't be helped.
We tried to tell you at first, but gave up.
Sorry.
I couldn't see.
Try to tell me things when I'm not playing the game.
You know what I mean?
Because otherwise I'm not going to see it at all.
Your mod DM... I don't even have Discord open.
Hold on, I'll do this.
Yeah, tell me things... Tell me things when I'm not playing.
Otherwise I'm never going to see it.
This should be good.
But you're MintoGaming.
I am MintoGaming.
I'm always gaming.
I got that gamer brain.
I got that gamer mind.
The gamer mind... Oh, ready to kiss!
Are you ready guys?
Get ready.
Get ready to kiss.
Oh!
Error.
You think this is funny, do you?
I'm trying to kill you.
Didn't you notice that?
Why are you always like this?
Why can't you just take things seriously for once?
What's that supposed to mean?
What is this backstory?
You know what?
I give up.
If this is all just a joke I might at least... I might at least be the last one laughing.
Zamora5.
Word from your boss.
Hey, I've heard you actually volunteer for the tunnels.
Is that true?
So no kiss?
Here we go.
Oh, shut up.
This is terrible.
This is the... Oh my god, no.
No!
Oh no!
Oh my god.
Is it... It's just her though, right?
She's already complaining.
Yeah, because I can see how hellish this is.
Zamora.
High tier shocker.
Oh, hello.
Oh my god.
That could be worse maybe.
Okay, nevermind.
Oh my god.
There's just electricity everywhere.
Please.
Is anything broken?
Oh, I see it over there.
Two of them.
This game kind of sucks maybe.
Oh, wrong.
No, I got the wrong...
Oh my god.
This sucks.
This is terrible.
This game sucks.
I changed my mind.
I don't like this game anymore.
Oh god.
Oh my god.
Just a simple little water briefcase.
Oh, here she comes.
Oh, come on.
Come on.
Oh shit.
Locked in.
Think of the kisses.
Hello?
Oh, okay.
I think I have to move.
Water.
I don't know if it's water.
I just think of it as a water briefcase.
What?
I was just trying to get out of the way.
Didn't give me a single chance to move at all.
It's craziness.
Alright, I'm just gonna keep running around.
Oh, I think...
Why did it have to be this?
Should be fine.
Oh, not fine.
Stay away from me!
Oh my god, that was so close.
The cross shockwaves come in three consecutive attacks.
Yep, I see that.
It's just hard to know where she's gonna go.
Oh.
It's hard to know where she's gonna teleport to.
Is the bigger issue for me.
I'm trying to... do this.
Come on!
Gosh, she's so fast!
Walking diagonals.
It's easier said than done.
It's a very tight spot.
Like, tight space.
Up here.
It's kinda rare.
Press spacebar.
Oh my god!
Yay!
Pie!
Pudding pie!
So fun.
Oh my god, please.
Okay, water.
I need to do eight?
Oh my gosh.
No freaking way.
Rude!
What am I getting?
Oh, this thing.
And... Oh my god, that was so close.
Gah!
Oh, screw that.
This game sucks.
Where was it?
Three.
Five, six, seven, eight.
Three more!
So close!
Oh, I was at six.
Oh, I thought I was at five.
Okay, okay.
Oh, no, wait.
I wanna... Okay, we're fine.
Oh, no, we're not fine.
You bitch.
You know you really are a bitch!
Fuck you!
Wait for both to be completed.
Alright.
What one's gonna explode next?
That one.
All the way over there.
How lucky for...
This...
I hate this game.
Why do I have to work for the ghost?
Why do I have to work for them?
I am a ghost.
Guys, you have to do this if you wanna kiss me.
I'm just telling you.
It's not worth it, is it?
Oh shit, I forgot to double tap.
Stupid as hell!
You bitch!
Bitch!
She comes straight at me.
Doesn't even give me a chance.
Definitely worth it.
I
mean, we're not good, but we're good.
I hate you.
Why do I have to... She's not even my type.
Why do I have to kiss the... Why do I have to go after the girl that's not my type?
So many times over again!
I'm not attracted to you!
But she's cute.
I'm not saying she's not cute.
I'm just saying she's not my type.
And I only wanna put in so much effort if...
If she's my type.
Tsundere with glasses?
It's not the glasses.
It's the...
It's the hairstyle.
It's like... It's just not my type.
If you want her, you work for her!
Screw you!
It's gonna be over here.
I knew it!
My sixth sense.
Oh wait, what is it?
Oh my gosh.
Oh my gosh, I don't know how I juked that, but I think I did it.
Somehow.
Oopsie.
Actually, that worked.
But... Oh, we're in trouble.
Oh, we're in trouble.
We're in trouble, we're in trouble, we're in trouble, guys.
Oh, grab, grab, grab!
Somehow I did it.
No!
Please!
It
was the last one, wasn't it?
It was
the last one, wasn't it?
No!
OK.
Sorry, I just gotta lock in.
I just gotta lock in.
OK, this side?
The other side.
I knew it.
I was literally about to say...
I'm feeling a little bit more confident about...
about her patterns.
I was reading her patterns really well last time.
I think I was just getting lucky, though.
I freaking knew...
Please.
VOD watchers, skip another hour.
Nah.
We'll get this.
What the hell?
It's always the other side.
Fuck you!
You fucking bitch!
Sorry for my language.
Oh, why did... Oh yeah, this one.
I knew it was gonna be the other side, though.
Just
let me fix this!
Again?
Oh shit, there's one over here, though.
Oh, no.
I wasn't paying attention.
I hate you!
One explode?
Shit.
Shit, shit, shit.
This is not good.
OK, OK.
Oh god.
What are these combos?
Why are they like the most difficult ones?
Oh, no.
I did not mean to do that.
But you know what?
This is fine.
Please be on this side.
Nevermind.
Be on this side.
Oh god.
Oh my god.
That was...
No!
Please!
Oh
my god.
I keep forgetting to double tap.
Why are they all the same thing?
What is this?
The game is rigged.
The game is rigged!
Shoot me.
I thought I could avoid it in time.
Oh my god.
Oh my...
The game was rigged!
Oh wait, why did I do that?
I'm so stupid!
Come on!
Oh
my god.
I thought...I thought I could get through it.
She'll get it this try.
You jinxed me!
Bahamut!
It's gonna be this one that explodes again.
No?
Oh, see?
I told you.
I told you guys.
Why?
Why me?
Girls who just say this...Fuck you!
Fuck you!
I would say I hope you die, but you're already dead!
I hope you never find love!
You don't deserve my kisses!
I hope your pillows are never cold!
I hope you never...I will never give you any of my pudding cakes ever!
Oh my goodness.
So rare for one over here to...
What am I?
Which one am I?
Oh.
Oh my god.
I'm losing it, you guys.
I'm regressing.
I didn't see where she went!
Everything was electrified!
I couldn't tell where she went.
Oh shit, I forgot the double.
I need to...I need that, please.
Okay, I'm lock...I lock in.
I lock in.
So fucked up.
I'm just gonna hold on to this guy for now on.
Oh wait.
Onto this guy.
Just gonna hold on to one.
Because those are the ones that take the longest.
Okay.
Really?
Now how am I supposed to do anything if you just...if you just headbutt me immediately?
How am I supposed to do anything if you just headbutt me immediately?
What happened there?
Oh, I gave up.
I just gave up.
Don't you?
Don't you, if you don't feel the run, you just give up?
Alrighty.
Oh,
I did it again.
Oops, I did it again with my heart got lost.
I hate you.
I don't know how I avoided that, but honestly, I'm kind of grateful that I did.
Oh shit.
No, I dropped something because I'm a stupid ass.
Wait.
Oh, I need the battery.
Sayonara everybody.
I didn't notice that one was over there.
You guys can, you know, be like Minto, why?
But don't like insult me, okay?
Don't insult me.
You guys can be like Minto, why?
But don't be rude.
Don't make rude comments.
That's all I ask.
You can be like Minto, why?
Don't be mean, okay?
Minto is doing her best.
I saw one.
I knew not to go left and I did.
I panicked.
What?
Two batteries?
Are you kidding me?
Oh shit.
And it's so hard to see everything in this damn game.
Oh, I should have put in my other guy, but I didn't.
You?
Ah, fuck.
I feel like her laser beam should be a different color.
There's too much green.
There's too much green everywhere.
It's hard to keep track.
Kiss the ghost now, bitch.
Yeah, but I like green.
You know, it's so true, bestie.
I like green too.
Let's go green woman.
Except this lady.
I hate her.
This green woman...
I would never say a green woman sucks, but when she does that, it really makes me wonder.
Do I actually like green women?
If you love green women, maybe you should try doing this part.
Wisps, take the wheel.
Please, take it from me.
I can't do this anymore.
Oh my god, I thought she's done already the third one.
No, I miscounted.
You bitch!
She's like, don't hate the player.
Just because you can't count, dummy ghost.
Dummy VTuber can't count.
Dummy VTuber!
Oh, I lived.
I didn't realize my drone was back.
Gosh, I can't believe I got to the last one at that one part and then totally blew it before.
Seriously?
Wait, how are there three things broken?
Are you kidding me?
No, no, no.
This is so unfair!
What?
I couldn't even concentrate.
There were three things broken.
No way!
What?
Rough RNG.
Game is rigged.
Hate.
I know I can do it because I got so fast.
That far.
Like, I got so... to the last one, you know?
So I know I can do it.
I just have to do it.
Except when she does shit like that.
Pisses me off.
You're pissing me off, lady!
You're not cute enough to do this!
I went outside so my dog can potty.
There was snow everywhere already.
It was his first time seeing snow and he went goblin mode.
That's so cute!
Alright.
I hate you.
I didn't even register because I got hit.
You fucking bitch!
If I fucking die again, I will become the Joker!
And this one too.
Oh, we're gonna die for real.
Wait!
Nevermind.
Please, sir.
Just some water.
Thank you for the Akasupa.
I can't read it though.
Why would you send it now?
I can't read it!
Wait, which one broke?
Oh god, they are both on the left side.
Water.
Hey Rinto, here's my birthday chat before I have to go.
It's amazing how much you've accomplished this year, although I couldn't catch the concert in person.
I'll be looking forward to other opportunities in the future.
P.S.
Don't give up kissing ghosts.
Thank you, Vector-san!
Happy birthday to you.
Happy birthday dear Vector-san.
Happy birthday!
Thank you so much for the Akasupa!
You're a charming person who is very peaceful to listen to, even when shouting about becoming the Joker.
Mercurial- Mercurially!
Is that how you say your name?
Thank you!
Wait, hold on.
I think I have this.
Hold on.
Yeah, I do.
Wait.
I was trying to get rid of it.
Wait, hold on.
There we go.
I'm not clowning around anymore, guys.
I'm not clowning around anymore.
I think I messed up.
Wait, hold on.
Let me restart.
Maybe I am clowning around.
Run diagonally, they say.
All you gotta do is run diagonally.
And you'll never get hit, they say.
Just run diagonally.
You'll never get hit a day in your afterlife, they say.
It'll be fun, they say.
Run diagonally, they say.
Run diagonally the correct way, VTuber.
VTuber, I told you.
Diagonal.
Diagonal, VTuber.
It's the only way to play the game.
Just simply be good and win the game, VTuber.
See?
Okay, where the hell is my hitbox?
If that was able to hit me...
I'm sorry.
What?
I was standing next to her.
So only sometimes does it work.
Wait.
Like, what?
Tell me the logic here.
You wanna know how I got these scars?
Straight up jokeler in it.
Okay, here we go.
Oh, nice.
Now don't screw it up, VTuber.
VTuber, if you were to mess that up... Really?
Fuck you, fuck you, fuck you, fuck you.
Is VTuber even trying?
I'm jokeling it.
Straight up the jokeler.
Guys, I don't even wanna think about the next couple of chapters.
This is 9, right?
Out of 13?
I don't even wanna think about the rest of them.
You know what pisses me off even more is I could've won potentially...
If there wasn't the damn time limit, which they get rid of in easy mode.
I hate you so fucking much.
It's so obnoxious when she corners you.
I hate you so much.
Diagonal, they said!
Diagonal, they say!
Diagonal!
Oh, just run diagonally!
Come on!
You missed the shot!
Don't even tell me!
You don't know what my fingers are doing!
Diagonal.
VTuber, your fingers are just not doing a good job.
VTuber, I know what you're doing.
You're just doing a bad job at what you're doing.
My ears are bleeding, sorry.
Alright.
I hate everything.
I hate everything!
What's the point of being a ghost if I... You know, once you die...
What's the point when you still have to suffer like this?
What's the point of dying?
That's why I say being a ghost is overrated, because I'm still forced to suffer like this and I can't die again!
This game is gonna make me straight for real.
But this...
Nobody will ever wanna kiss a ghost again.
Fuck you.
That's why we're here.
Just to suffer.
Please, thank you.
Oh, come on, I pressed it!
No!
Fuck you, I went diagonal, everybody.
Please, let it be known.
Mental phantom went diagonal.
Shit, I was already holding one.
I shouldn't have gone up.
I was already holding it.
What's the point of me grabbing it if I forget?
Let the record show, I went diagonal and I still got hurt.
Sick of your sass.
You remind me of sea salt caramel ice cream.
Saltiness brings out your sweetness.
I have no sweetness.
You know it's over when Mint gives up on the girls.
It's so over.
Oh please.
Oh my god.
Yes.
Let the record show, I went diagonal.
I went diagonal.
You can just go.
The wrong diagonal, VTuber.
Oh, it's this guy.
Hi dad, have you tried only moving in counter-clockwise semicircles?
Like this?
Oh wait, why counter-clockwise?
Why can't it be clockwise?
I hate this game.
I hate this game so...
I don't know how I made it, but we did, baby.
Lucky.
Lucky, lucky.
Shit.
Why clockwise?
Why not clock-dumb?
Roller, you're asking the best questions.
Why clockwise?
Why not clock-dumb?
A clock is correct two times a day.
If it is dumb.
A wise clock...
Is just a guy.
A wise guy.
I went diagonal.
Let the record show, I went diagonal.
I want everyone who ever told me to go diagonal to shut the fuck up.
Every time I go diagonal, and it doesn't work.
It doesn't work.
It only depends on where you're standing.
Diagonal does not always apply.
See?
I went diagonal.
I went diagonal, and it didn't do shit.
You guys are so full of shit.
I swear to god.
My tears.
Screw everything.
My afterlife.
Oh my god, we're up to the...
No, no, no.
Oh, I thought I was dead there.
I don't think it's... I think I'm gonna lose it though.
I mean, I've already lost it, but you know what I mean?
Like, there we go, see?
I think though, they were gonna explode.
Having three of them is too much for me.
Okay.
I've been playing Minecraft, and it got me thinking this.
Somebody get this woman on a Minecraft server.
I need to see her build a giant mud temple.
Why a mud temple?
I
wish there was a dodge button.
Like a little dash.
Dodge dash and all.
I wish.
It's messed up.
Stop dashing at me!
Tis the season.
You know Dasher and Dasher and Dasher and Dasher.
Dasher and Dasher and Dasher and Dasher.
But do you recall?
Oh my god, I tried picking it up, but I wasn't close enough.
The most annoying ghost lady of all.
Dasher, the ugly ghost lady.
Everyone thinks she's hot cause just her glasses.
But she is actually so ugly.
Your appearance doesn't make you a good person.
She's so ugly with her stupid personality.
She might be the ugliest ghost I've ever known.
And if she doesn't stop dashing at my face, I might just rip her nose off.
Alrighty.
Stop dashing at me!
You know Dasher and Dasher and Dasher...
Oh, why did I pick that up?
Oh my god, I didn't see where I...
I didn't see where she went.
That was my bad.
It's not even her name.
I don't remember what her name is.
Jarvis?
Now that's what I call the Christmas spirit.
Thanks guys for humoring me in my time of need.
What?
You always go up, why do you go down now?
Why did you change?
You've changed, Jarvis.
You've changed.
You're not the same ghost that I used to know.
Battery.
Please.
See?
There was only one picture there, you guys.
I swear.
There was only one little question mark there.
And then it turned into two pictures.
It turned into a...
Oh, we're dead.
There was only one.
They always show only one question mark.
Yeah!
And earlier I was just like, I wish that they showed two question marks when there were two items.
And everyone was like, what are you talking about?
They do.
No!
They obviously don't.
Focus... I am... OK, you guys don't need to yell at me to focus, OK?
I am focusing.
It's just that sometimes...
I don't see which one is counting down.
I'm not reading chat!
I only read chat when I'm not playing the game, OK?
You guys don't even know what I'm doing.
Stop acting like you know my afterlife, OK?
You don't know me!
You don't know me.
Ah,
shit.
I don't know why I did... Oh, that's why I did that.
Wait, I just need this.
Perfect.
I think that was the last one.
Oh, God.
It's because I thought...
I thought I needed this one.
Instead, and then I... It's OK.
NT, NT, NT.
We're focused, everybody.
We're focused.
We're focused, we're focused.
Oh, nice.
I was reading pretty... Reading her movements pretty well there, though.
I think I got the decent RNG, all things considered.
Oh, no.
I got the timing wrong on that.
It's my bad.
She also... OK, correct me if I'm wrong, but does she only...
When she does the...
It only goes in three directions, right?
Or is it... I don't think it goes in all four.
So, you have to... It is four?
Oh, it's a full cross.
OK, so I guess it depends.
I think I'm only noticing, like, sometimes if she's, like, here.
Because, you know, I'm so close to the walls all the time, because that's where the generators are, that...
It only looks like three, because it'll be like...
And I don't see, like, the top.
Or she'll be here.
It just fizzles if she's close to the wall.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Oh,
I forgot to do that again.
I'm an idiot!
I did it again.
Wait.
Huh?
Oh, it's because I pressed the...
Wait, does anybody need this?
No?
Guys, I messed up.
Goodbye, world.
I messed up.
Two
times in a row.
I really... I diagonaled.
I diagonaled.
Two times in a row.
I did this, this...
I did.
Let the record show.
Oh, nice.
I mean so.
Diagonaled.
When she needed to.
Oh, I'm holding it.
Ah,
shit.
Shit.
Shit you.
I hope you shit your pants.
But you have to kiss her afterwards.
I will not!
This lady deserves no love!
This lady deserves to live like Miss Haversham for the rest of her life.
After life.
She's dead too.
I hope she lives like Miss Haversham.
Forever!
Imagine angry kissing.
She probably has stinky breath.
Unlike me.
I taste minty fresh.
But this bitch tastes probably like bad Gatorade.
Oh, I need...
And yes, I...
I
didn't notice that.
I don't know how I made it past that.
Oh, wait.
No!
Wait.
Nice.
My eyes are actually starting to glaze over.
I'm not gonna lie.
My eyes are starting to glaze over a little bit.
It just becomes so much.
That I'm like...
That I'm like, there's... I just can't...
I can't focus anymore.
Oh!
It's just so many flashing lights.
And...
You have to be so like...
Focus.
You have to be so focused the entire time.
Or else it's just like you miss like...
One of these guys pops off.
Or wherever she's at.
Or anything, anything.
Gotta give you props for always having the most subtly savage burns, Mikito.
So think about the time you wish someone would grab their belt or pancreas.
Would you give this to Mito for Christmas for me?
Thank you, Zachary.
Sparks!
Happy birthday!
Happy birthday to you.
Happy birthday dear Sparks.
Oooooh.
Shit.
Screw you.
Lady.
You're so ugly.
You're so fucking ugly.
She didn't like that.
I don't think she liked that.
May all her chocolate chips be raisins.
Actually, I prefer oatmeal raisin cookies, though.
I actually prefer oatmeal raisin cookies.
What do you mean, huh?
What, because I'm not trying to rot my teeth?
I don't know about that take, boss.
Well, I'm not force-feeding you the chocolate.
Look, okay?
Think of it this way.
We're both sitting at a table.
There's two cookies on said plate, on the table.
One is chocolate chip, one is oatmeal raisin.
Now you can have the chocolate chip and you can have the full cookie.
And I can have the oatmeal raisin.
And everybody is happy.
Faced oatmeal raisin gang.
Alright, let's get this.
Oh, you know what?
Oh, come on.
Seriously?
Oh, I didn't see how low she was.
I didn't see how...
Whenever anybody is just like, Oh, you should like the same thing I like.
In terms of food.
Isn't it better?
If we like different things?
Because then you can have all of the thing that you like?
She's very low.
That's normal for Garbage.
Like someone once told me, Don't say ick to another's yum.
Exactly.
Don't yuck somebody's yum.
I steal the other's food.
So I get to eat double.
So messed up.
Shit.
Sometimes I get caught on the walls.
Which really sucks.
Oh, come on.
I hate you so much.
The walls make you lose all momentum.
It sucks.
It does suck.
I don't want to kiss ghost girls anymore.
I hate it.
I'm anti-ghost girl now.
I'm changing my image.
I'm reincarnating into something else.
I literally press enter as I was passing that.
Like, come on.
Don't be like that game.
She's gonna become a gnome.
Game's so hard it makes you want to punch the ghost, not kiss him.
Right!
I had trouble with a couple of the other levels.
You know, I'm not a gamer.
But this one...
It's tilting me just a little bit.
Luckily, it usually...
Oh, I hate her.
It usually ends so fast that I...
You know, it's easy to just retry, luckily.
Oh, I went to the wrong one!
Oopsie.
There we go.
And I forgot to press it again.
Oh,
come on.
Why?
Oh shit, oh shit, oh shit, oh shit, oh shit, oh shit, oh shit.
We're so dead.
Good matter, thanks for the five gifted.
Lucky, thanks for your gifted.
Sorry, I can't see who's gifting stuff.
Thank you, Phantom.
Thanks for the ten gifted.
Thank you so much.
Thank you, guys.
I really appreciate it.
Blow up.
Wait!
Oh, it's because I'm holding two things.
I was gonna say, where's my other thing?
I'm stupid!
That was totally my fault, though.
I was so... my...
Water.
Please, drone, come back.
Drone, I miss you!
Drone!
I miss you!
Uh-oh.
Guys, I don't think we're gonna make it.
My
hand is cramping!
Oh, my hand is cramped!
I hate people like you.
I hate people like you so much.
I'm just saying, I bought this game, downloaded it and 100%ed it during the duration of this stream.
I'm... OK, maybe I'm just being a little spicy today.
But like... but like... OK.
Seriously?
Like...
First of all, it's free.
You didn't buy shit.
OK?
And second of all...
I feel like people don't understand what it is like to stream and also play a game at the same time.
Like, shut the fuck up.
You're so obnoxious when you come to...
I'm just saying.
Also, everybody comes from different walks of life and afterlife.
Like, just because you can do something with perfect ease doesn't mean everybody else can do it with your skill level.
OK?
I bet I can do a million things better than you can too.
But you know what?
I don't come into your life and say...
Oh, gosh.
I did this so way faster than you did.
I'm just saying.
It takes...
It takes nothing.
It's free.
Just like this game.
To be nice.
God!
Sorry, I've been holding that in.
Just joined stream and Minto is destroying someone.
It has to be said!
And that doesn't even just mean with the game.
You know...
That's everything in life and afterlife.
That's everything.
Anki enough to turn into a poltergeist.
Nah, I'm a poltergeist.
Poltergeist when you start throwing things.
Water?
Sorry for being spicy.
I went diagonal.
Let the record show.
Minto went...
Diagonal.
Not there though.
Usually, if I go off on people, it's in good fun and in jest.
But...
That kind of comment actually tilts me.
You know...
Things like that where someone is just like...
I could do it so like this.
You should be able to do it like that.
Oh, flip spawn thing.
Maybe you should be the streamer then.
Nice.
Oh, wait.
No!
It cancelled out my double tap.
Oh, we are already at the three.
Oh god.
Wait,
this one...
I can do.
But this one...
Oh no.
Wait.
OK.
I can do it.
Nice.
This one though...
Guys, I don't know if we can finish this one in time.
I'll try.
You know...
Dasher...
Dasher and Dasher...
And Dasher...
I fucking hate you.
I just gave up.
I'm not a clown.
Yeah, I'm Rudolph.
But do you recall...
The most manky reindeer of all?
I turned down the difficulty on this one.
I'm so invested.
I don't feel like I can anymore.
I'm like I can't turn down the difficulty.
I won't do it.
Do you recall...
Oh shit.
The most manky ghost of all?
I didn't double tap.
I'm sorry sir.
I'm sorry.
Manky the double tapper.
Except when she doesn't... Why do I have two of these?
Except when she doesn't do that.
Fucking... I deserve to die here.
I deserve to die.
I deserve to die there.
We're so close you guys.
I can taste it.
The sourness of her breath.
Cause she's nasty.
This is one ghost nobody wants to kiss.
Why did you go back down?
You damn bitch.
You know that?
You know how nasty you are?
Nobody will ever kiss you.
Ever again.
Nobody wants to kiss you.
I can see why, honestly.
Fuck, I got stuck on the wall.
Dasher and Dasher and Dasher and Dasher.
Dasher and Dasher.
Dasher?
I hardly even know her.
Is this from the Helltaker guy?
It is.
It is, it is.
What do you recall?
Sorry, this is how I'm coping, you guys.
No, Jengon, don't jinx me, please.
Never say it's the run.
See?
Don't jinx me.
It's too much pressure.
Oh my god.
Jinx intensifies.
I'll take a hit for that one.
You guys, isn't it so great?
The longer I take on a level, the more we stream.
Oh, this will be a really fast stream, they said.
It's not a very long game.
Yeah, but think of all the content.
Oh my god, I hit enter.
I hate this game so much.
Oh wait, there we go.
Dasher and Dasher and Dasher and Dasher.
Please, leave me alone.
Leave me alone.
I've learned my lesson not to mess with women.
I'll never say anything perverted about a woman ever again.
I promise.
I'll never try to kiss women ever again.
Oh, it's this way.
Just kidding.
I'll sell all my doujin.
Lies and deception.
Not the doujin.
I'll sell my tickets to Comiket.
I'll read BL from now on.
Oh, the horror.
Yo, this game is messed up.
I can't believe it's been an hour and I still can barely read her moves.
So messed up.
She's just too good at teleporting and being fast.
But definitely not being sexy.
She sucks at that.
Oh my god.
She's so fast.
She is so fast.
Do you recall the most dashing dasher of all?
I'm not dashing at all.
I haven't dashed.
My eyes are just... My eyes are literally jelly right now.
Oh, what the hell.
My eyes are such jelly, you guys.
What is this one?
I didn't mean to zigzag that, but I did.
Oh shit.
There is always something happening.
When
is the meeting?
In an hour or so.
My meeting is in an hour or so.
I don't think I'll beat the game.
That's OK.
I think I'm going to uninstall it.
Eat a pudding.
Yeah!
Why don't you guys ever give me pudding?
Pudding pies.
Where is my pudding pie?
I think I deserve it.
I deserve it after this.
What flavor pudding do you want?
You never ask.
OK, Solid Snake.
Pudding pie.
Come on, man.
Where the hell even was she?
So much.
You are not sexy enough to be like this.
You are not.
You are not my type enough for me to give risk at all for you.
Oh my god, I got stuck on the wall.
Oh, and I forgot to double tap, baby.
Forget to double tap.
I love it when she's stupid.
I love it when she can't control anything.
Did I grab that?
No, because she attacked me.
I didn't notice the one in the corner.
I was like, I wonder where the other one is.
I was so focused on trying to get the one.
The one in the corner keeps betraying you.
Roller, I don't know how to break this to you, but all of them are in the corner.
Some are in the corner.
What
do you want from me, game?
Honestly, I like... can't even pay attention to the floors because there is so much else to pay attention to.
You know, there is so much else to pay attention to.
I'm just like, I can't even know... I just have to run and I have to hope.
I just have to run.
That's the hardest level in the game?
You think so?
And
then sometimes... Look at that, I ran right over it.
I didn't get shot.
It's kind of inconsistent, I feel.
I feel, but maybe.
Running and hoping seems to work.
It's my only hope, honestly.
I just have to avoid her.
Such bullshit, man.
But I got greedy there.
I blame myself there.
I got greedy.
I got greedy, greedy.
Oh, OK.
You guys are just responding to Vector.
I already wished you a happy birthday.
You're just responding to the old message.
You guys are so cute.
You got this, I believe.
Thank you!
You can do it, Miki.
I'm doing my bestest.
Maybe not my bestest.
Bestest would be not having a stream and no performance anxiety.
At least I double tapped.
Wait, what?
Oh, come on.
I just keep getting stuck on the walls.
I keep getting stuck on the walls.
Can you guys imagine if I tried playing this?
If I had tried playing this...
4 years ago.
There's no way I would've been able to do anything.
I got mad at Yomawari.
I'm malded at Yomawari.
I would've been able to play this.
So if anything, the fact that I've managed this so far...
is I guess a bit of a...
Fuck you.
Fuck you, I said.
Fuck you, guy.
I don't know who raided me.
But if anybody tells you to play this game, don't do it.
The ghost kisses aren't worth it.
They're not worth it, I promise you.
Don't do it.
Don't play.
Avaria, don't do it.
It's not worth it.
Don't do it.
Save yourself.
Don't play Avaria at midnight.
Oh, fuck me.
Don't do it.
It's not worth it.
Minto, you inspired me to try this and it's way harder than it looks.
You know what?
Thank you.
Thank you for saying that and not being like...
Oh, I beat it in the same exact amount of time.
So you make me feel less like a failure.
Were there any other games that made you mad when you were streaming 4 years ago?
Yeah, Yomawari.
Yomawari made me mauled for the first time ever.
Look how far we've come.
Oh, wow.
I got got by the floor two times.
I want to see.
Let's see.
Hold on.
Oh, you just don't have a little guy.
Oh, so it's a one hit kill.
Oh, that's it?
Guys, I appreciate you having faith in me, but...
Don't.
The generators are also slightly faster.
Oh, the timer!
The timer.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Oh, I need a break.
My eyes are so glossy.
My mom just texted me and it's just like, here's what you need to pick up for Christmas.
I didn't even... She didn't even ask me.
I didn't even know I was meeting her for Christmas.
She said, let me know... Wait, she texted my family group chat.
It was like, oh, let's do something the 26th instead.
Let me know ASAP.
I have to order it tonight.
And then 20 minutes later, ordered it.
And then said, here's the pickup order.
Go get it, Minto.
She didn't even ask.
I didn't even think that we were meeting up.
I thought I had Christmas free.
Because my mom told me she was going to be out of town.
Oh my god.
I was going to stream.
Surprise!
But not the 26th, apparently.
Does anyone else's parents do that?
My mom is notorious about just volunteering people.
Here's what you need to pick up for Christmas, Matara.
No, leave her to rot.
Yes, yes, yes.
Voluntold.
Yes, that's exactly it.
Oh my gosh.
No.
Okay, I'm going to go get a drink real quick.
Maybe I shouldn't have played this game on just coffee.
Because I'm shaking, baby.
I'm shaking.
I'm shaking 30 whispers.
Such a mom thing.
It really is.
I'll have, like, friends come over...
And my mom will be like, hey, by the way, can you and your friends, like...
Break the leaves in my yard?
What do you mean?
What do you mean by that?
Sending you good vibes.
Hope you have a good meal later.
Thank you!
Sounds like your mom volunteered to stream.
The mom tax.
My mom does the same thing.
Is it just a mom thing?
I don't understand.
She makes the guests work.
Yes!
And she never asks beforehand.
She'll just be like, okay, you're going to do this.
Okay, let me go get a drink.
Let me go get some water.
Or, GamerSubsCodeBoomer.
GamerSubsCodeBoomer?
For 10% off your order?
Wait, wait, gamer... What would it be?
What's a gamer flavor?
Guys, name a flavor.
And I'll let you know if I have it.
Nice plug.
Thank you.
Piss.
Shut up.
Lemonade!
I have lemonade!
Lemonade is a gamer drink.
I'm going to go get some lemonade.
I'll be right back!
You guys, I made lemonade.
And, and...
I put raspberries, fresh raspberries in it.
I put raspberries in it.
I wonder if I should try controller.
I know I'm used to...
Hold on, my controller is connecting.
I know I'm used to the keyboard by now, but I'm wondering...
Even though I don't know what these controls are.
My health?
We'll try it out.
Oh, I'm so stupid?
I think... Oh, OK.
Oh god.
I might be an idiot.
No, really, Mito?
No, really?
Fresh water!
Delivered.
Baby.
Fresh water.
Oh, you bitch.
How close did I get?
6 out of 8?
7 out of 8?
Yeah, I was close.
OK, maybe... I actually feel so much easier on controller.
I should have switched earlier.
Thank you so much.
I don't know.
For the don't know...
The gifted membership.
The donated membership.
I can't think anymore.
OK.
Maybe I should have switched so much sooner.
Isn't that just so funny?
OK, never mind.
I tried to dodge and...
Everything was ruined.
My whole afterlife.
Ruined by this game.
And I can double tap way easily.
Way more easily, too.
I said that and then...
Now all I need...
Couple thanks for the gifted.
Thanks!
OK.
Oh.
There we go.
I'm still ending up getting stuck on walls, though.
Water!
Fresh water.
Screw you.
Screw... Oh wait.
Alright.
So
many...
Where was it?
This way.
If I can like clip around...
Like the wall when she tries to dash at me...
It's way easier to...
Oh, whoops.
That's not what I meant to grab at all.
Stupid.
Actually, maybe it's fine.
I need... I need that little guy.
Where's the last one?
Oh no!
The time!
Wait,
bitch!
You're so fucking ugly!
Die alone!
Oh my gosh.
I think I would have completed it so much more quickly if I had just switched to controller.
I'm a fool.
Now kiss her.
I don't want to.
You guys can have her.
Dead hole!
Thank you so much for the 50 gifted.
Thank you!
I gave it everything I had and you still refuse to die.
You're good at this, Ula.
I'll give you that.
Wait, how do they know my name?
I thought they lost their memories.
Rat bag!
Thank you for the 5 gifted!
Thank you!
Common mint toy.
No.
Thank you, thank you.
Bad dog!
Thank you for the 50 gifted!
Thank you!
Bingo game.
Wait,
Ula, that's your name.
It's Ula Lestarka, right?
But how do I know that?
Look!
They're starting to remember.
They're starting to remember their big old polyamorous relationship.
This company is freaky.
This is a freakier game than I realized.
Hurt the eyes.
They're doing the doki.
The doki.
It's as if... It's like I remember you from before the...
Sorry, creator.
Thank you.
I know you.
You are... I have it in the back of my head.
Ah, forget it.
I don't need to know who the hell you are.
One day you'll make a mistake and I'll finally kill you.
Yeah, not today though.
Definitely didn't.
First try everybody.
I'll make it slow ripping you apart limb by limb.
Here you guys go.
You can have this one.
This isn't me.
The reverse!
Wait, I don't want you guys getting kissed by ghosts.
You guys can't be kissed by ghosts.
You guys got lucky today.
Too late, you said it.
You're lucky today!
But it wasn't me.
It wasn't me.
Hi, not so tough now.
Oh my god.
That's so cute.
Not so tough now, are you?
It looks like this time I've emerged on top after all.
You know what?
After all of that...
This character does deserve the kiss rather than the ghost.
The ghost deserves nothing.
I can't believe you just did that.
Chapter 10, question mark, question mark, question mark.
Where's that little pup from sector F?
We can't afford to lose anymore runners this week.
I'll go check on her.
Wait, drinking this stuff leads to death?
What does that mean?
Oh my gosh, I'm not Ula anymore.
Hello?
Dash?
Wait, what is Dash?
Oh?
Oh, huh?
Why did I have to use all my dashes up?
Oh, ouchie ouch.
Dang, she's fast.
She's really fast.
Oh, there's water?
Oh gosh, I haven't noticed who... Oh my god, it's all of them.
This is so evil.
I'm getting lost in the sauce.
I'm like, what do I need?
What do I need?
Ouchie ouch.
Wait, I can keep dashing?
Oh, I can keep dashing.
Oh!
Oh, I didn't realize.
I thought there was... Oh, ok, ok.
I was like, why did they have me use it up if I'm just gonna...
I was like, what's the point?
The scraping of the thing is so creepy.
Come over here.
What do I need?
Water.
Ouch!
Ok, so dash is not invincibility.
Got it.
Wait, you can dash through projectiles.
Wait, dashing has eye frames.
But I tried.
And I tried dashing through the... But you can't dash through the ghost, I'm guessing.
It is?
Wait, then why didn't it work?
I just landed on her.
Oh.
Isn't that so silly?
Oh, Metal Gear.
How many are there?
Eight?
Oh, this game is torturous.
Oh, shoot.
I'm getting so lost in the sauce.
Holy hell.
Oh my god, it's so much to look at.
Oh, I'm getting so lost in the sauce.
Oh my goodness, it's so hard to keep track of everything.
Information overload real.
There we go.
Oh, there we go.
Seriously?
Oh my god.
Wait, so is there a cooldown on the dash?
Yeah, a bit.
You can't like spam it.
Oh, I forgot she spawned there.
Oh, hello?
So fast.
Come on, stop camping.
She turns around so fast.
Oh, that's not what I meant to grab.
You know what?
Shit.
Oh wait, this works.
This one.
And water.
Wait, please.
Oh shit, I didn't press that.
You bitch.
I don't know what's broken.
Oh wait, I need you.
Was that the last one?
Dang.
Almost had that one.
Yeah.
All done.
See, we know we can do it.
Gosh, the switch to controller makes this so much smoother.
I swear.
It's so much easier.
It's so much nicer.
Oh.
Alright.
Wait, I thought that was broken.
This one is broken.
What's the broken one?
Oh, there it is down here.
Oh please, please.
Oh, it's the...
Damn.
What's the broken one?
Oh, I ran into it.
You were nerfing yourself for no reason.
I know.
It's okay.
We know now.
NT, NT, NT.
Everybody, NT, NT, NT.
Oh, I need metal gear.
This one.
It's hard to find what I need.
Please.
Oh god, oh god, oh god, oh god.
Where is it?
Where is the broken one down here?
Metal gear.
You.
Oh my god.
Oh gosh.
We just keep dodging past her?
Oh shit.
I tried.
Water.
You, you, you, you.
Guys, I keep getting stuck.
Nah, we're getting close.
We're getting close.
I'm just, you know...
It's when everything... You have to clear your brain.
It's like when you're playing a rhythm game and you have to not focus on the notes.
But sometimes I forget what's the order of operations, you know what I mean?
I'm like, oh god, what do I... I tried to dodge there and it didn't work.
I'm like, what items do I need to create the thing?
The flow state.
I like this level a lot better though.
I can say I like this level much more though.
Than the other one.
Even if it's three of them.
It still feels more manageable somehow.
Ouch!
Oh, I have two of these.
I just keep grabbing batteries.
I wish though...
The knife, the other cutter girl would come in after you do a third thing.
That's my only like...
Oh my god, I did not... Oh my god.
This level without dash would be diabolical.
Oh, I don't think it would be possible.
Honestly.
If we didn't have the dash, I think it would be...
Actually impossible.
Whoopsie.
Oh, come on, I pressed it.
Please don't be like that.
Oh, I got stuck on the wall.
What's wrong with you?
Actually, I asked myself that same question everyday.
Oh my god, it's so easy to get...
To get cornered.
It's so easy to get cornered in this one.
Corn nerd.
Yeah, I am a corn nerd.
What of it?
Yeah, I love corn.
What about it?
Yeah, I'm a corn nerd.
Did I grab it?
Oh, I did.
Okay, good.
Why
can't the game give you, like, one second of high frames, please?
I swallowed my spit wrong.
Blood for the blood god.
Trill.
Oh, okay.
Oh, I dashed, but I think I... Oh wait, I went to the wrong one.
Don't you have a meeting?
Yeah, in 40 minutes.
Don't worry.
You don't need to baby me.
I know what time it is.
I'm all good.
Now, I don't think we'll be able to beat the game today, but...
You know.
Baby.
Coughing baby.
I know it's hard.
It's easy to think I'm a coughing baby because I do the baby cough.
Oh, damn it.
Shoot.
At least they give you a little bit of wall to dodge...
That one.
Girl, if you need to...
Coughing baby.
Sorry, just making sure you remember.
No worries.
Appreciate it still.
Thank you.
Thank you, thank you.
Oh, these machines suck.
These machines are pretty bad, I think.
Oh my god, I dodged though.
I...
I dodged.
See, it doesn't really help if you dodge right into the...
The damaku.
Dodge is a common phrase in these last few levels.
Everybody is feeling the pain.
Clearly.
God.
What are you?
Oh my god, there's three of them?
Okay, I need the water.
I need...
Oh shit.
Oh my god, I just needed to not run into it.
And what about you?
I dodged!
You guys, I dodged!
I pressed dodge and I didn't go down!
I didn't.
I pressed dodge.
I did, I did, I did.
Ran straight into it.
Yeah, because I was trying to go down.
I was trying to go down.
Oh wait, I lost my thingy.
I love when that happens.
There was like no way getting out of that.
I love when they are all in one area.
Like, leave me alone!
Okay, this one over here.
Oh my god.
Wait.
Okay.
Oh no, Metal Gear.
Come on!
Don't be like that.
Please be nice to me.
Oh, I grabbed the wrong thing?
I grabbed the wrong thing?
Oh, I'm dodging into the wall.
Oh my god.
Oh my god, the time limit!
I don't have time.
Oh wait, I do have time!
Can I live, please?
A clutch!
Yeah!
One second, let me...
Make sure I'm not being contacted.
Okay, good.
Yeah!
Hey there, love.
I'm looking for a friend of mine.
Short, quiet, gives away pudding pies.
Rings a bell?
Cool down, old timer.
We didn't manage to off the new girl, if that's what you're thinking.
Yeah, it was Dr. Striga who got her.
If you hurry, you may still find them in the lower tunnels.
Oh no!
We're going to the lower tunnels!
Word from your boss.
What?
Can't she stay put for a single bloody day?
What the hell is wrong with her?
No, we got kidnapped!
Okay, guys.
We have three chapters left.
I would like to see if I can...
Well, I only have a half hour.
I would like to try to beat it today.
Because I don't want to play it again.
I have a half hour before my meeting.
Do you think it's okay if I play on easy for the last three?
So I can try and beat it?
Yeah?
Okay, thank you guys.
Ultra tier scrapper?
Oh my god.
Oh my god, they're fast.
Oh, we're already on...
There's everything going on at once!
It's like that movie!
Everywhere!
Everyone all at once!
Holy shit, did I have to do...
Oh my god.
Where's the water?
Oh, there's no time limit.
God is gracious.
God is good.
Oh my god!
There's no time limit!
Thank god!
Oh my god, I'm stuck on the wall.
God damn it!
Oh my god.
Oh, I forgot that I can dodge.
I'm so stupid.
I've been so... I was so...
So...
Do I even want...
Hello?
Which is that one?
I'm trying...
Oh, I was looking at the wrong one.
Okay, okay.
This one.
Ouch.
Oh my god.
Not stupid.
Brain boiled.
True.
Oh my god, they don't even give you a second to learn anything.
They're like, welcome to the game.
Oh, I tried dodging, I did.
I'm so lost in the stars right now.
Thank god there's no time limit on these.
What kind of weirdos say this?
Please, it's not Iron Man!
Oh my god!
Oh, I thought I grabbed it though.
I thought I grabbed the water.
Oh, damn it, damn it, damn it, damn it, damn it.
Damn it, damn it, damn it, damn it, damn it.
Please just fix one.
Please.
I can't even fix a single thing.
I'm so lost.
Please.
I'm so...
I'm lost!
I'm just a girl!
Please!
I can't stop running.
I love no time limits.
I'm just a girl!
Look, sweetheart.
This is Baba Yaga.
The legendary tunnel runner.
She's supposed to be off-duty today.
Oh, isn't it Baba Yaga?
Oh, wait, I'm so confused.
I can't read anymore.
Wait, look, sweetheart.
Isn't it Baba Yaga, the legendary tunnel runner?
She's supposed to be off-duty today.
Sylvia, you dumb bitch!
We had a deal!
Two days, Sylvia.
I have only two days off each year.
I really shouldn't be working right now.
Somebody...
Wait, where's our kisses?
Word from your boss.
Sorry about this, pup.
Usually I'm more successful at keeping my ghosts contained in sector A.
Sector A?
Oh, it's so embarrassing pressing easy mode.
I'm sorry.
There's nothing to block hits here.
It's gotta be all skill, baby.
OK.
Oh,
dang it, I dodged, but I think it was timed out.
Oh, gosh.
Oh, gosh, what am I missing?
OK, here.
Oh, wait, I grabbed it.
I grabbed the water.
I'm dead.
Oh, come on.
Be nice.
Don't be like that.
At least it's only two.
My god.
Anymore?
I'll literally pass out.
If there were any more than two, I would literally pass out.
Minto...
Minto's head.
Shit.
I grabbed that for, I guess, this reason.
There we go.
Oh my god, are you kidding me?
We were so close.
I think.
I think we were close.
Actually, I'm not quite sure.
This bear is too fast.
I actually can't tell what animal it is, because it's so...
It's so fast.
I can't tell what I'm looking at.
Damn animals.
Those...
Oh my god.
I'm gonna die.
Probably.
Oh, come on.
Wait, it didn't explode in the timer though.
I thought I was safe.
I thought I had the timer.
If I get close to it, does the timer go down more quickly or something?
Or...
Yeah, see!
I thought I had the timer, you sick game.
Oh wait, I didn't need that.
I grabbed this thing and I don't need it!
What do I do with you?
Game doesn't follow it's own rules, that's what I'm saying!
Oh my god, I'm so dead.
I'm so dead.
I guess if it's like...
Don't get close...
I don't know, I have no idea.
See, look at this!
I'm so confused!
Oh wait.
Nope, I'm not carrying it at all.
Ouchie, ouchie.
I'm forgetting what controls are.
Please, please.
Oh my god, I ran right into it!
I do this every time.
Uh oh, I'm so boned.
I'm so boned.
Oh my god!
It's alright guys, I believe in us.
I believe...
Oh, okay.
Wow.
You wanna tell me when you...
When you dash next time?
We know Dasher!
Dasher 2.0!
Dasher 2.0 baby!
Heal, heal.
Fixed.
Okay, alright.
Oh no no!
Oh come on.
How am I supposed to dodge that?
I have a battery and I don't know why.
I just grab things.
I just grab things because I think they'll be helpful.
Emotional support battery.
Oh
god, I got double teamed.
Oh, I thought that was me.
No!
Hold on.
Reminder on meeting in 20 minutes.
See you then!
Today
guys, so sad.
Wow, that was fast.
I don't think we're beating the game today you guys.
I'll just YouTube the ending.
I can't do this anymore.
Put me out of my misery.
Oh my god.
I'm trying.
Wait, where am I?
I can't tell when I'm doing stuff.
I got lost.
Crikey, this place is scary.
There we go.
Please, let me out.
It's hard when they're all getting up on me.
I think that's just what they're doing.
I dodged.
I dodged game.
Ref!
Ref, I need you to...
I need you to call this one.
Ref!
Referee!
Where's the referee?
Where's the ref?
Oh my god, there's so many guys on the screen.
Oh, oh, oh, I already...
Shit, shit, shit, shit, shit, shit.
You know what?
Screw it.
There's no time limit.
Who cares?
I don't care!
I actually do care.
Shoot, shoot, shoot, shoot, shoot, shoot.
Please, this is the last one!
Let me live!
Oh god, oh god, please.
I dodged!
Oh, I was literally spamming dodge.
Oh, spamming it.
So rude.
Oh gosh.
Oh, you bastard.
You ugly fucking... I'm gonna burn.
You know what?
I hate animals now too.
I hate everything!
I hate everything.
I've become a certified hater.
I've become a certified hater of all mankind!
All creatures of all species!
I hate women, and I hate animals, and I hate men, and I hate everything!
I think nothing should survive!
I hate everything equally.
Nothing will escape my wrath.
This is why I'm a Yurei, you guys!
If you ever wondered why.
You're like, why is Kayako her queen?
Why does she want to be like Kayako?
Because of this.
No one is safe from my wrath.
Ouchie ouch.
I don't even feel like I'm comment...
You guys, I think I've blacked out the past 15 minutes.
Have I been talking?
I
was like, wait a second.
Am I even commenting right now?
Am I commentating right now?
Or am I going insane?
I can't remember anything that I've said in the past 15 minutes.
Oh my god!
I've literally blacked out.
I can't believe it.
I was like, wait a second.
Is this even interesting to watch?
Am I talking?
I don't know if I've been talking or not.
I have no idea.
Craziness.
Have I been talking?
At all?
Guys, be honest with me.
Oh my god, I dodged though, I dodged.
I dodged, I dodged.
I mean, like, I pressed the button to dodge.
Oh my gosh.
I'm not, like, creating any new things though.
Oh no, I haven't been creating things.
I haven't been creating things.
Oh gosh, oh gosh, oh gosh.
Ouchie, ouchie.
Oh my god, you fucker, you fucker.
It was more growling than talking.
I became Godzilla.
This
is my Godzilla impression.
Wait, what am I grabbing?
I'm running in circles.
I'm just running in circles now.
What do I need?
I need water.
I wish I could tell how many hits I had left on my little guy.
My little drone man.
Okay.
Oh my god, I tried to hit, or I tried to do anything.
Wait, I think I got hit, like, three times.
Drone has only one hit.
No, it has two, because I'm on easy mode.
I'm on easy mode, so it has two hits.
Holy shite.
Oh, it's one hit, but it respawns.
I thought it was two.
I see, I see.
Six seconds between hits.
I'm sorry, you guys were right.
I admit fault.
Which I do not do often.
I hate this.
What are you?
You're an abomination.
Oh my god, he's really gonna kill me.
I gave up, I gave up.
I just gave up.
Oh shit, this game is free?
Yeah, better be!
For the amount of rage I have!
You think I wanna pay for this kind of rage?
You think I wanna pay to be this angry?
Oh,
I was like...
Oh, am I...
You guys are so...
Guys, I think this might be it for me.
I think this might be...
Last try.
Last round.
Last round for Minta.
Oh my god.
Please.
Maybe if I just focus on one side...
You know what I mean?
Actually, I don't think I can.
Oh my gosh.
I heard all those little bunnies break.
Your little fragile bunny bones.
Die bunnies.
And your little fragile bunny bones.
Bones.
Become bones.
Ouch, nevermind.
He didn't like that one, but he was the chosen one.
The strongest bunny.
Oh my god.
I can't do anymore, you guys.
I can't do anymore.
I can't do it.
I'm too weak.
I'm so frustrated.
But that's okay.
Maybe next time.
You still did great tonight.
Good luck at your meeting.
Thank you!
You're almost done, yeah?
But I have a meeting in five minutes.
It's okay.
If I didn't have a meeting, of course I would keep going.
But since I have a meeting, I have to give up.
I have to give up.
It's important.
If only I had switched the controller sooner and beat that other level faster.
Then I could have probably beat it.
Maybe.
So frustrating.
I was like, what's in my drink?
I forgot I put raspberries in it.
I was like, ew, my drink is moldy.
I don't think I'll play the game again though.
Sorry.
I don't feel like playing it just for two levels, honestly.
But, you know.
Thank you guys for watching.
Thank you.
Still a fun ride.
It is a fun game.
I like this level.
And I liked the previous level.
These levels, after that one girl...
I don't even care to remember her name.
After that, though.
You know, after I switched the controller.
Because it's so much more smooth.
Oh god.
They're calling me.
Osaminto, everybody!
Thank you!
I will see you guys later!
Bye bye!
See you!